the father of an unarmed michigan man
killed by police is demanding
prosecution of the officer who shot his
son peter leoya who emigrated with his
son from the democratic republic of the
congo spoke to reporters through a
translator
police video released on wednesday
captures an unnamed officer pulling over
26 year old patrick leoyea on april 4th
saying his license plate did not match
the car hey stay in the car
stay in the car
as the officer tries to arrest him he
runs that one
then a scuffle the officer climbs on
leoya's back captured on video by leo's
passenger in the car the officer's taser
goes off
missing leoya there is an apparent
struggle for control of the
taser then the officer reaches for his
gun
and fires
civil rights lawyer ben crump hired by
the family calls it murder you see a
police officer
police
grand rapids police have turned over the
investigation to michigan state police
by the time when i saw this video
my heart was really deeply broken
now the family who sought safety in the
u.s after fleeing war in their homeland
will have to go on without him john
hendren al jazeera